- He jumps up.
"You want some? Like Deebo. You want some too?"
I'm like, "No, I don't!"
- Welcome to "Untold Stories."
I'm your host, Master Tesfatsion. We've had
12 incredible episodes in Season 1, and
what better way to have a season finale
than here in Miami, in South Beach during
Super Bowl week? And
I'm excited for my next guest.
He is a New Orleans native.
He is a Hurricane great, a national
champion, a Ravens legend, a Super Bowl
champion, a member of the NFL 100, a Hall
of Famer and one of the greatest safeties
of all time.
I hope I'm doin' you justice with this
introduction. Ladies and gentlemen,
please give it up
for Ed Reed.
[Applause]
My man. What's up, baby? How you doin'?
- I'm good, man. No complaints, man.
- How's retirement been treatin' you, man?
- Retirement is semi.
Um, football is a short-lived career,
you know?
So I had—you have to plan for, you know,
the next chapter.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, yeah, I'm retired from football, but
I'm still around it.
I'm still doin' a lotta things.
- With all that planning you're doin', do
you get time to,
to play pool or nah?
- A little bit, man.
I got a pool table in my house, so, you know—
- All right, cool.
I shoot a lil' bit every, every now and then.
But now it's the ping-pong, table tennis—
- Oh, that's what you on?
- Yeah.
- All right, before you grab that stick now, I got a,
I got a gift for you, all right?
Since you the OG,
you're in a pool hall,
I gotta make sure the OG feels
comfortable.
- Always.
You know, I heard you're a big cigar aficionado.
- Yes, sir.
- So, Akshay's got some cigars for you here.
- Whoa now.
- Shout-out to Glenn, who told me this is one of your
favorite brands right here.
- Yeah, man. No doubt.
You know what?
I actually got my cutter in my lighter.
- See?
- So you take this right here—
- All we need is the ashtray.
- Never leave home without it.
- Lemme hold this for you right here.
- Yeah.
- When did you get into cigars?
- Got some nice Plasencias here.
I got into cigars in college, man.
And, um, me and Bubba Franks—
- College?
- Yeah, me and Bubba
Franks used to go hit golf balls all the
time, losin' golf balls.
And, um,
I was smoking Montecristo and, um,
Arturo Fuente and Reggie Wayne called me
and was like, "Man, I got some premium
sticks for you.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So I'mma hook you up." And sure enough,
that's what he did, man.
And it's been good since then.
- All right, you can go ahead and get cut up real quick.
- Yeah, so I got a dual cutter.
I got the V and the straight cutter.
- Is that what you do? Lemme see.
- Yeah, so you got the V, straight.
I'mma go with a V cut.
Actually, I'mma crown cut it,
which most people
just, like, don't really know too much about.
You know what I'm talkin' about? Crown for a king.
- Yeah.
- You smokin' with me or
I'm by myself?
- Uh, you gonna smoke with you right here.
I'm gonna smoke after to celebrate the
season, all right?
- Say no more.
- That sound good? Does that sound good?
- Say no more. More, the merrier.
- While you doin' that, while you lightin' that,
go ahead and grab that stick.
- I'll take two.
- Hopefully that ashtray
don't fall down. And hopefully I get this
break right.
Oh, I scratched on the first one. Damn.
- You haven't been practicing much.
All right, lemme see what I got here.
- Table open for you.
- Shoot this one ball in the side pocket.
Just a little touch.
- All right, man.
We gonna have a conversation or
you just gonna play the whole time?
- Oh, no, man. I'm witchu. Let's do it.
- Seven in the side.
- Oh, you good.
Go ahead.
- I can talk and play.
Talk and play pool.
I don't talk and play football.
I ain't got time for that. I'll leave that for
the divas.
- I'm, I'mma go ahead and let you hit this
five ball, but I'mma start this conversation.
Before we start to talk to you about your career,
uh, the sports world been struck
with tragedy this week.
- Yeah.
- With the passing of Kobe Bryant, not only just
in the sports world, but we've seen how
it's impacted everyone around the world.
- Yeah.
- Wanted to get your thoughts on, on where
you were on Sunday and how that has
impacted you this week.
- First, I mean, prayers out to all that
was, um, affected. All the families that
was affected and the Bryant family.
You know, um, it's tough, man.
You know, I always say, none of us know
the day or the hour,
um, when, when God would call us home. You
know, this is, uh, this place we're in,
man, it's rented.
We rentin' this place.
You know, this is not our true home,
you know? And I, you know, when, when
somebody passes, it's, it's very unfortunate,
you know, especially when it's young and
a mother and dad gotta bury
their parents, or, you know, a daughter.
You know, and the husband, man, that,
that's, that's, that's very hard to deal
with, you know? But we're left here with
the memories that we won't have, and that
we, we hold on to it.
And that's the, that's the hardest part,
you know?
But all we, all we take from this place is
memories.
- Yeah.
- That's all you take.
when you leave, man.
You ain't takin' no money, ain't takin' no jewelry.
All you takin' is the memories,
you know?
- Did you have any memories with Kobe?
- Or should I say you're leavin',
you're leavin' 'em.
I mean, I grew up watching Kobe.
I'm the same age as Kobe, man. Forty-one,
you know? And where I'm from, you don't
make it past 14, you know?
So I'm grateful to be where I'm at right
now, man.
But, um, cuz I grew up watchin' Kobe, man,
since he'd been in the league, since he was
in high school.
You know?
I mean, how do you not, you know, watch
what he's done on and off the court?
You know, I'm a big philanthropist.
I love workin' with kids.
And, and the things he was doin', man, how
he's transcended the sport, you know, as a
human being off the court, man, how you
not watch that?
You know, how you not emulate that?
You know, I always looked up to the greats.
You know, Michael Jordan was one of them,
was my favorite player.
And, and knowing that Kobe was, Kobe was
everything, just like Mike, you know?
And, um, that, that's the feeling I thought.
Like, man, that's like losing Michael Jordan.
You know what I'm sayin'?
That's losing the great players.
Muhammad Ali,
you know? So, very, very sad
um, day for the world, you know? And it
just so happened I woke up and read
Proverbs 1—Proverbs 27:1, on that
morning, you know? And I actually put it
in the, um, Instagram today, just Proverbs
1.
You read that, you know what I'm sayin'?
Man, it just, it helps me, you know,
because when, when you experience that,
all of us bein' that it's, you know,
Kobe.
If you experienced that in the last year,
two years, five years—
we deal with it different—
so it brings those feelings back.
You know, I lost my brother when I was
playin' in the league, man.
And, um, I know how tough that is.
You know, I've been just small texting
with LeBron, just, you know, givin' him
words and encouragement and, um, you know,
you just never know what somebody's goin'
through, man.
So I just wanted to reach out and just
say, you know, "I know it's hard, man, but
stay strong."
You know?
- Everyone knew about the Mamba Mentality and
the work ethic that he put in, not only on
the court, but in everything that he
applied himself to do.
I think we also know you for your work
ethic as well, and, and the,
the effort and the dedication and the
attention to detail that you put into
everything that you, that you apply yourself to.
- Yeah.
Where did that come from?
- Man, that come from my parents.
You know, um, I'm, I'm their seed, you
know? It's in them, you know? But
I had a lotta mentors too, man.
You gotta have a great circle of people
around you if you wanna be successful in
life, I think. Um, if you wanna achieve
great things, you gotta have the right
people in your circle.
It's who you surround yourself with.
I tell this to kids all the time: "You show
me your friends,
I'll tell you who you are."
- True.
You know, me and
Mr. George was talking about that last night.
you know, man? And that's truly what it
is.
I've always surrounded myself around
God, God-fearing people,
you know, and, and follow God in people.
You know, that was, that was a big part of
just livin', you know? My, my parents
worked hard, man.
My dad worked at Avondale Shipyard for 30 years.
My mom worked in kitchens, you know, for
20-plus years.
And that's the reason why I cook, you know?
So I mean, just the things I knew, they
went through me.
I feel like kids are supposed to take over
where their parents left off.
You know, parents build it to a certain point.
Kids supposed to be workin' out, training,
playing sports, goin' to school, gettin'
good grades, and when they get old enough,
you're supposed to take where your parents
left off and build up on that.
Not go your ass back home and puttin' the
milk, puttin' your name on the milk and
stuff like that.
You know, that's not what it's about.
You know, I really believe your parents,
and I always say this to my kid and say it to
a bunch of kids, your parents are raisin'
you to leave the house, not stay.
- They don't want you back in there.
- True story.
- Lemme see if I got any shots right here real quick.
- Yeah, you make shots, man.
I'm a defensive guy.
I'm a defensive guy, man.
- You said I was right?
- There's a lotta blue in between here.
- Oh, you think I'm scared?
- Yeah.
Lemme get this cigar goin'.
- Go ahead, get that goin' while I'm gettin' this shot.
- Shouts out to the fans that's over here.
- They got a couple folks out here, man.
I didn't know y'all was gonna have a live audience.
- We gotta do it right for you, man.
- I feel like I'm shootin' one of the "Martin"
shows or something.
- Who, uh, who taught you the game of football?
Where'd you learn?
- Man, when I was born, man. I mean, I
always say I was born to play football.
You know, it was just in me. You know, my
dad was a super athlete, played everything.
I played every sport: baseball,
basketball, ran track, soccer, you know.
So I always said I was born to play
football, you know?
And truly it was one of the only ways out
of my neighborhood in Metarie, you know what I'm sayin'? So,
when I was five years old, my brother
tossed me the ball and was like, "Get past me."
My older brother, you know? I played a lotta
street football,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Pole to pole, lamppost to lamppost,
mailbox to mailbox.
Cuz I got a scar on my head from runnin' into
a mailbox when I was, like, 12 years old.
I caught the ball too.
- How did that happen?
I gotta, I gotta hear this story. Because I
know that your Hall of Fame bust, everyone
always talks about how beautiful that
bust is, the attention to detail to that bust.
- Man, I gotta picture when I was, like,
seven years old.
I always had hair on my head, but, um,
bein' that football is such a physical
sport, you know, I, um, I felt like havin'
a lil' cushion, you know what I'm sayin',
would help me out.
You know, you get—football is a violent sport.
A lotta concussions, stingers and such
like that, man.
So, I know it's just—it was in my nature.
It's part of my culture, you know?
Um, you know, I see like, like we're
dealin' with a lotta
ignorant stuff these days, man.
Especially when it comes to kids and
school and their hair, you know? Like this
one kid in Texas, they askin' the kid to
cut his hair.
- Dreadlocks.
- Yeah, man.
- It's crazy.
- The kid been wearin' 'em since—for a long time.
Like, that has nothin' to do with school.
But that's the ignorance that we're
dealing with, you know?
So for me to wear like this, you know, I
know I need to cut it at times, but
it's just natural to me, man.
I'm comfortable in my own skin, and
that's what it's about.
You gotta be comfortable with who you are.
- So I gotta hear the mailbox story.
OK, so you caught the pass, but what happened?
How—did you see the mailbox?
Was it yo—oh, you gettin' fancy.
- No, I ain't see the mailbox.
- You doin' the Martin Luther King
shot right here on me right now, man.
- I am Martin Luther King.
Part of. Um, naw, man, we was playin' on this
spot called the playground, and the guy
threw the ball, and I'm runnin' like this.
I'm runnin', lookin' for the ball, but
it's, you know, it's—I'm outrunnin' the
ball basically.
So I'm lookin' at it like this right here.
And as I catch the ball,
I hit the mailbox. And you know how kids
are. I got the ball in my hand. They like,
"Let us see! Let us see!"
And I moved my hand, and nothin' but blood.
I passed out after that. My dad did all—
next thing I heard was like, "Your dad's
goin' your way, on his way to come get you."
You know?
So that probably was my first concussion, man.
- You get stitches or surgery? What—
- I had stitches.
I had stiitches. I had, like, 16 stitches, man.
- And how long did it take for it to heal up?
- For life.
I'm still bruised.
- I gotta ask you:
So you, you're a guy who grows up in the
New Orleans area.
It feels like you were born to play football.
Why did you choose Miami?
- Y'all might wanna stand up and look and
say, "Why not Miami, right?"
Go stand by them stairs, man.
I mean, I wanted to get away from home.
You know what I'm saying?
I felt like my, my environment was not,
um, not healthy enough for me to do the
things that I wanted to do.
Um, I grew up around—on my way to school, man,
I'd pass up three plantations on my way to
high school—
- Wow.
- I pass up three plantations.
You know, I do—I did a golf tournament
five minutes from my high school,
not even. You could walk to this golf
course. In 1990,
my mentor,
they were still not able to go to this
golf course as black people.
You talkin' in the '90s, you know what
I'm sayin'?
So I just didn't wanna be around people
who just had that old-school mentality,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Like, that's still in the South, you know?
You still see it in Mississippi.
My people were from Mississippi.
My family's from Mississippi.
- With the
prison reform situation and all that.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
So,
that stuff,
that stuff means somethin' to me, man.
I'm a people's person.
I used to live with my, my, um, secretary
of my high school.
She's a white lady, you know? Her family's
Caucasian, white, you know? So I lived with them.
That's my family.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So I saw things—
I see things different, man.
I'm not—I don't, I don't—I'm not out
here judgin' people and "You're racist."
I don't do that,
you know?
It is what it is.
But I wanted to get away from that, man,
and I felt like—I felt like Miami was
gonna be different. And come to find out
it wasn't too much of a difference, you know?
- Ain't that the truth?
- But, but I really wanted—I mean, I wanted to
win a national championship, you know?
I wanted, I wanted to win a national
championship, and thank God we did.
You know, I actually got my ring on right
here. You know, so that, that's what it was about
to me, man. It was about playin', playin'
at the highest level, but puttin' myself in
position to also make it to the NFL.
You know, I was a businessman at a young
age, man.
- That 2001 team, considered one of the
greatest, if not the greatest. You think
it's the greatest?
- Yeah.
Yeah. In college football?
- We got some Canes in the house over here.
In college football?
I mean, I don't have to, I don't have to
shout out the records.
I don't have to shout out the
first-rounders, but I'mma just talk about
two people: myself and Sean Taylor.
Sean Taylor was my backup.
He wasn't even starting then, and he's a
beast. Hall of Famer in my eyes, you know
what I'm sayin'?
Antrel Rolle, those guys like that.
Jonathan Vilma, all first-rounders, you
know what I'm sayin'?
So we, we—we was on another level in
college, but it was about our coaching staff.
That's what people don't talk about.
It's the people who have guided you, man.
Everybody should have a mentor,
you know what I'm sayin'?
But we had men raising young men, you know
what I'm sayin'?
And that's what it was about.
You know, you gotta—you need guidance as
a, as a young man, as a kid. When you get
to college, women—young, young ladies
and young men are becoming men now when
they get to college, you know? It's the
real world.
- People growin' up so much faster now.
- Exactly.
Exactly.
They have access to everything, right,
at the touch of their hand.
You know, so,
I don't know, man.
We just had a great coaching staff.
We had Super Bowl-winning coaches: Coach
Davis, Curtis Johnson, Chuck Pagano, Art Kehoe.
I can name so many guys.
Mario Cristobal, who's head coach at
Oregon now.
We had a lotta great men leading young
men, and that's what we need now.
We need us men to lead our men,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Lead these young men, these young kids.
We need that more.
You see the women doin' it.
Women gonna be overtakin' over
this world sooner than later.
I mean, I'm with that though.
I mean, we gonna have us a woman
president, you know, runnin' this thing.
Because, I mean, they, they stand together,
you know what I mean? They stick together.
You see all kinds of women groups doin'
all kinds of things, man.
You know, and we need to, we need to stand
up as men and, and take hold of
what we supposed to do too.
- Is it your shot?
- Yeah, it's still my shot.
- Go ahead.
- I don't have nothin'.
- I don't think you gonna make anything, yeah.
Cuz I ain't made nothin' yet.
- I'll give you a shot now.
- Go ahead.
- Somewhat.
- Thank you.
- I'll help you out.
- This is a charity donation.
- Now, look, I went to Arizona State.
I also grew up in Texas.
Wanted to escape my situation as well, and
I went—had the same experience you did in Miami.
I was like, "Why the hell would I wanna
go anywhere else?"
Arizona State is a party school.
I had a good time in my four years, but I wasn't
a prominent football player at the
University of Miami.
- Right.
- What was the party scene like?
What was it like bein' the man on campus
and the man in Miami?
- The party scene could wait.
I never came to the beach when I was in college.
I never crossed that bridge when I was in college.
Um, you know, I, I understood to do the
things that I wanted to do, man,
I needed to be around my teammates and
stay close to that school.
Don't get me wrong.
We had some times when we,
you know, when I got—I was older, man. I
was 21, 22 when I graduated, you know? I
stayed five years.
So it's how you handle things, man, at the
end of the day.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I had a lotta fun, but when I got to my
senior year—we'll just talk about my
senior year. We didn't party during the week.
We partied after the game.
We can get—you can do whatever you want after
the game, but that week, man, just chill out.
- Why?
- Because there's a focus time, man. It's
work. You know,
you got—you,
you're playin' a physical sport.
We put a lot into, as I say, I put my
heart in this shit. You know, in the
offseason, as we did,
let's not waste this opportunity.
High school, college goes by like that.
Even the career in the NFL, it goes by
like that.
I'm 41 years old, man,
and retired from, from football.
Like, I'm a retired—when people ask me what
I do and go to the bank and I'll be like,
"I'm retired."
They'll be like, "What?
Retired?"
But now I say "Semiretired." Semiretired.
Retired from football, but I still do
other things.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, you gotta have a plan, man.
So I knew that it was a short-lived
career in, uh, in college.
I knew it was gonna go by like that,
and I wanted to enjoy it.
I enjoyed every moment, man.
- I gotta ask you about one specific moment while
I take this shot real quick.
I heard, Ed, you've got a story about
Shannon Briggs. Who is Shannon Briggs?
- Shannon Briggs.
That's pretty funny right there, man.
Shannon Briggs was a boxer.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
A champion boxer.
- Word?
- Very elite boxer.
- How big we talkin' here?
- Man, Shannon, Shannon Briggs, I mean, when
he stood up, he looked like King Kong, but—
About 6'5".
- That's a big-ass dude.
- But he's huge, man.
Solid, too.
- When I say you solid, man—
- What, what happened?
Word on the street is you and Shannon Briggs—
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Had a little somethin' somethin' that happened.
What, what happened that night? And did you know
he was even Shannon Briggs?
- I didn't know.
We didn't know he was Shannon Briggs. So—
- What happened?
- Long story short, we got this clique—
- Nah, I need the long story.
I need the long story.
- All right, yeah, I'll give you the whole story.
We got a group, the, the class of '95.
I'm class of '97. Class of '95 was known as Two Gs cuz
they graduate in 2000.
- Two Gs?
- Two Gs.
- OK.
- So, it's me and Bryant McKinnie.
Bryant McKinnie and I are the youngest ones with
them hangin' out, and we're on the beach.
Now, we done cross the bridge, right?
And that's why we never crossed the
bridge. There's nothin' but trouble.
So we come to the beach with the older guys.
Me and Bryant McKinnie are the young guys. We're in the
club, and one of the older guys come back
in like, "Y'all gotta come on! Let's go!
Let's go!
Um, "One of our teammates just got knocked
out!" Like, "Knocked out?!"
"Yeah, he got in a fight.
Let's go!"
So we like, "All right, cool."
We walkin' through the, um,
we walked through the back of the club in
the alley.
Then we walked through the alley to Collins.
As we comin' through, I'm actually in the
front, and the, and the guy, you know, my man was
like, "They right there."
So I'm lookin'. I'm like, "So, what's up, man?"
Like, "Why y'all jumped on our boy?"
"Why, you know, why you knocked him out?"
And lo and behold, he jumps up.
"You want some?" Like Deebo.
You want some too?"
I'm like, "No, I don't! But I got a bunch of cash
with me, so—"
- Who was with you?
- Me, Bryant McKinnie, um...
I'll just leave it at that—
- OK.
- And, like, five other Two G guys.
- Once you said McKinnie, I knew—
- Bryant McKinnie.
- You in good hands.
- Because when he said that, and I'm like, "Nah,
man, we just tryna
figure out." Bryant McKinnie come through.
Bryant McKinnie is, if you had never saw Bryant
McKinnie—
- How big is he?
- Bryant McKinnie is, like, 6'9", 300-something at
this time. Needless to say, Bryant McKinnie
didn't give up a sack in Miami.
So Bryant McKinnie comes through. "Wait, wait, wait!
Get the—"
He was like, "Get the little guy."
So there's two of them, Shannon Briggs and
the friend or whatever.
So, I come around, whatever, hit the lil' guy.
He's pretty much outta there.
Bryant, Bryant grabbed Shannonn Briggs by his
dreads. Yanks him down like he's Dwight Freeney.
He's on the ground, man.
And they just,
they whalin' on him now.
I mean, they are goin' to town on him,
right?
And he's just on the ground on his all
fours just takin' it. "Ooh, ooh."
Right?
So I go over there.
By the time I get over there, man, this
guy's just took off runnin' outta the group.
He's gettin' kicked,
all kinds of stuff, right?
So we go back in the club. I'm like, "Man, I'm done.
I'm ready to go home now, man."
We gotta find our boy though.
So we finally get him.
We're on—
we're, like, Collins and 17th.
- So how far is that from here,
right in this location
we're in in South Beach right now?
It's not even two streets over. Like, we're on 17th right now.
Like, this is 17th. We're, like, right here, and he's at
Nikki Beach.
Nikki Beach is, is um, Ocean and 1. You
know, Ocean and 1st.
And you like, "What—how do you get down
there that quick?"
He ran down there, dude.
Like, Shannon Briggs kicked your ass.
You know, so that, I mean, that's kinda
how it happened, man.
That next day, dude, we had practice.
We walkin' out there sore. Like, we got in a
boxing fight.
We didn't know that it was Shannon Briggs
at the time.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Until he actually got sued by my boy
cuz he broke his jaw.
You know, you can't—boxers can't fight on the street.
Those are weapons, you know, so he wound
up gettin' sued
and everything.
You know what I'm sayin', so.
- So are you cool with Shannon Briggs now?
What's the relationship—
- I never even met him man!
Never even saw him after that.
And I hope you not watchin' this right now.
- We'll take that from, from there and go
straight to the NFL,
OK?
You're finishing up your rookie year in
the NFL with the Ravens.
You say you flipped a switch after your
rookie year.
Why?
- Yeah.
Cuz I, I understood to have—
when you get to the NFL, you hear, "Not for
long," and it's true, man.
- Average NFL career's, what, three seasons?
- Yeah,
that's because the numbers are skewed
because of free agents comin' in and out
all the time.
It's a cutthroat business, man. I always said
it was like the drug game.
They don't care.
They get rid of you in a minute.
So, when I got there, you hear "Not for long."
I was like, "No, I need—a need for
longevity."
You know what I'm sayin'?
Like, "I wanna get longevity out of this.
I wanna have a career.
I wanna play a long time."
- Cuz you spent your whole childhood
preppin' for this career.
- Yeah, man.
And, you know, I got a Hurricane that with
me in Ray Lewis, you know? And, um, I
already knew a bunch of stuff about work
ethic, workin' out and stuff, man.
But Ray had a chef, you know? He was
livin' a certain way. Ray had a mansion in
Baltimore, you know, so.
It wasn't so much as
like, "Lemme get the mansion and everything."
But the things that, at least I can say,
if I wanted, I can get it.
You know what I'm saying?
Cuz there's a difference between a
want and a need.
- Absolutely.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
And I didn't want it.
I didn't need it, you know?
But if I can say now, where I'm at now,
shit, if I want it, I can go buy it.
But at the same time, you gotta have the upkeep.
So I was like, "Man, you gotta eat right.
You gotta work out. You gotta train."
And, quite frankly, I did enough, um,
havin' enough good time here in Miami in
college to where I can put the partyin' down.
And that's what I did.
You know, me and Bryant McKinnie used to go
out all the time.
- He was also in Baltimore too.
- Man, Bryant McKinnie lived right
directly across from me in the condos in Brickell.
And he know I'm not lyin'.
He used to have this party bus.
He used to pick up everybody. "Man, come
on, Reed. Come on downstairs."
I'm like, "Whatcha talkin' about man?"
Like, "We goin' out." I look off the balcony.
"Man, I'm not gettin' on that bus!"
You know?
But, um, yeah, man. I put it down.
He's like, "Reed, you changed. You changed, Reed."
And I did, man.
I mean, I was—
- When was he sayin' you
changed? When did people notice that?
- I mean, I was reading the Word more,
you know, and, and, and just finding
myself, you know? I was finding myself.
- How old were you?
- I was 23, you know, and killin' that old guy
that, that, that was—I felt like was
draggin' me down.
You know what I'm sayin'?
That could be people, it could be yourself.
You know, if you feel like you've been
dragged down, man, you gotta change some
things. You know, as, as me and my boys
say, you gotta take inventory on yourself
and your surroundings, the people you
surround yourself with.
- That's real.
That's your shot.
I missed it
while you were talkin' about the South
Beach story. I couldn't focus.
I couldn't get locked in.
But you gave me one already.
You gave us a donation.
So on top of the Miami Hurricanes, do you
always wear 'em on a rope like that?
- Mhm.
- The chains?
I see you got the, the Ravens chain—uh, ring on too.
- Yeah, this some—I feel like this is a
Miami thing cuz the first person I saw
do it was Trick Daddy.
- Oh, yeah?
- Yeah.
- When'd you see him do it?
- Man, this is
back when I used to be runnin' with Trick.
Trick took care of us.
Took care of my family,
you know, at times when I was here in
Miami, you know. And, um, Trick, tend to
get a bad rap, man, but he's a really good
dude, man.
And he truly do cares about the kids, you know?
And, um, he loved Miami.
And, uh, when I was here, man, I used to
always be around him and his homeboy Twenty Two
and just, just hangin' around.
And, um, if somethin' was 'bout to happen,
he'd let me know,
"Reed, you need to get up outta here.
Get your family. Let's go."
You know?
But, um, he was the first person I
actually saw do this.
And, um, I just kinda take it from there.
Man, he was—I always called him Unc. I'll call him
Uncle Trick.
You know, I haven't seen him in a while,
but yeah, man, he, he was a big part.
He was a big part of, um, growth, for
me in college.
- So you got the 2012 Super Bowl ring
wrapped around your neck as well.
- No, no, no.
This is my Hall of Fame ring.
- Oh, your Hall of Fame ring.
Oh, OK.
- Yeah. This is my Hall of Fame ring.
- That joint big too.
- Yeah,
it's the biggest.
I can't even fit it.
I don't think nobody in here can put this on
their finger.
- Where's your Super Bowl ring at?
- The Super Bowl ring is actually back at the hotel.
Um, the diamond off the first Super Bowl
came off, so—
- Oh, we gotta get that fixed.
- Yeah.
But I wasn't a part of that one
anyway, so...I'm not trippin'.
- What do you take away from that year, though?
Cuz you guys, during that season,
you got your ass whipped by the Texans.
- Yeah.
- There was a bye week that happened.
- Then afterwards, what happened during
practice that week?
- Man, we, we had a
meeting with the coach.
We had a meeting with Coach Harbaugh, um,
before the team meeting. Team meeting's at 8:30.
We had an 8:00 meeting with the
head coach in his office.
He's like, "Guys, I'm thinkin' about
puttin' y'all in pads for the bye week.
We were like, "Coach, no way.
We're not doin' pads, man, in the bye week."
You know, like, we're an older team. We don't need that.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And he was like—long story short, he was
like, "All right, I'm not gonna do it.
We're not gonna put you guys in pads."
Man, we walk right downstairs, and Coach was
like, "All right, we're gonna put you
guys in full pads."
We was like, "No!"
And so I raised my hand. Like, "Coach, come on, man.
You just said, you know, you wasn't gonna do that.
You can't go back on your word."
And he was like, "Yeah, Ed.
I changed my mind walkin' down the stairs."
I'm like, "No.
Nah, man, you can't, you can't do that to
us, man."
You know?
So that led to Bernard Pollard gettin' up,
standin' up, and then it got heated. At
some point, Bernard is yellin' at Coach Harbaugh.
And it was like, "Tell him, Ed!"
I'm like, "Whoa, I already said what I had to say!"
You know, he threw me back in that fire,
man, and I, you know, I chimed in, but it
really, it really resonated when Haloti
Ngata—who don't say nothin'
he's a gentle giant—
um, is my guy, and everybody know Haloti
don't say much.
Haloti was like, "Coach, you did tell us that."
And when Haloti said it, the team backed
it. And that right there brought us together.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Cuz that was, that was, that was goin'
into the playoffs, man.
We had to go to Denver. We had to go to
New England.
You know what I'm sayin', so—
- It was a tough road.
- Yeah, man.
And we was already on that, as I can use
now, on that Mamba Mentality
of every day, workin' hard, man. Anquan can
tell you. Ray can tell you. Sizzle can
tell you. Every day,
we did the same stuff all the way up until
the Super Bowl.
You know what I'm sayin'?
We had some bumps in there, some speed
bumps that you gotta go over.
That's natural.
That's life, you know?
But it was, it was, it was somethin' that
really brought us together.
- What are you always gonna take away
from that season?
- Man,
the memories, man.
Just bein' with my boys at practice.
You know, the, the dedication that they
put into it, the discipline, you know?
- Practice is, practice is
one of those memories that are always
gonna pop up for you?
- Oh, yeah, man.
A locker room.
You know, we, we had a cornhole
tournament that year.
- Who won?
- I think Sam Koch won. Sam Koch won.
- Oh, Sam Koch?
- Yeah, the um—of course, they got all the time in the
world! Our kickers, snappers and punters.
They in there.
You walk in there, they throwin'
cornhole, you know?
So, that was that, man.
That was something that—but that was just
bringin' us together.
Um, I remember we—I used to, I used to
tell the guys, "Don't eat at the facility
after practice." And we used to all go to
Yuki Sushi and just have drinks and just
sit in there, man. It's gettin',
gettin' to know your teammates away from
the football field, you know what I'm sayin'?
- Why was that important?
- That's very important to know your coworkers, who you
workin' with, man.
How they are, you know what I'm sayin'?
How are they gonna handle things away
from the business? That tells you a lot.
If you—so, you might see, I did this—I did a, um,
sitdown with Joe Buck, and I put, I put my
teammates on blast, but I had already did
it in the meeting, where I told 'em, like,
"Bro, we got volunteer firemen around here,
and y'all grown men throwin' your trash
right in front of the garbage can."
They would miss it and leave it there
cuz they know somebody was gonna
take care of it, you know, or leave their
towel in the shower.
Man, you can imagine bein' in the locker
room, going into the, in the shower,
and dirty towels are everywhere on the damn
knob that you gotta turn the water on.
- What'd you take that as a sign of when you
saw that?
- Disrespect.
It's disgusting, and that's stuff kids do.
I'm correcting my son on this,
and y'all doin' it?
No way, man.
This is your house away from your house,
your home away from home.
You know what I'm sayin'?
When I lost my brother in 2011, those were
my family members to hold me together.
So this is our home.
But more than, more than anything, respect
those firemen, dude.
They're grown men, dude.
They shouldn't have to be pickin' up after you.
They're not your maids.
You know what I'm sayin'?
And if we wanna win a championship—me
and Ray had this conversation my rookie year.
He was just like, "Bro, we gotta do the
little things, man."
Cuz little things, if you don't do the
lil' things, it'll turn into big stuff.
- There's always alpha males and egos in the locker room.
You and Ray Lewis
are two alpha males that I feel like, in
terms of a leadership perspective, kind of
approach things differently.
- Yeah.
- But it seemed like you always were able to mesh.
- Why?
- Cuz, man, look, I didn't care.
I didn't care who got the glory, man.
I come from Miami, where we had many stars.
We had a lotta first-rounders.
I come from Miami, where we were pushin'
each other to be great.
That's what I come from around, and that's
what it's about.
There's enough out here for everybody to have.
They print money all the time.
They print money as we speak.
That's enough for everybody.
So all we gotta do is just encourage each other.
If we work together, if we work together,
we gonna win. And everybody will have
an opportunity to do something, to be in the league.
My whole senior class had a opportunity
to go to the NFL and went to a team.
What you do with that opportunity's on yours.
I was gonna put mine in a chokehold, as
D.C. Young Fly would say.
Shout-out to 85 South. Them my boys.
But, real stuff, when you get that
opportunity, man, you gotta put it in a
chokehold. Cuz if you don't, somebody
else, especially at the University of
Miami, was right behind you waitin' for
the opportunity.
- As you shared,
Sean Taylor was behind you.
- Real stuff!
And I wasn't havin' it.
It wasn't happenin'.
No.
I'm playin' with three broken legs.
- How beneficial was it for you to have Ray
Lewis at the start of your career in the
NFL to kinda show the leadership
and guidance of how to adjust to the
professional level?
- Man, it was key to have Ray, Peter Boulware,
Derrick Mason, Matt Stover.
It was a lotta leaders, man.
It was not just one leader, you know?
I know that people that always saw me
with Ray, and we were, we were like peas in a pod cuz
we was Hurricanes.
We were always together, but it was Monte
Sanders who was with us too,
our trainer.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Rohan Marley that was with us.
We trained in Jamaica together, so it wasn't
just Ray, man.
You know what I'm sayin'?
It was many people, cuz not every time
me and Ray saw eye-to-eye, you know what
I'm sayin'?
But I didn't care.
I don't care.
I didn't care who get the glory, man.
I can care less about that.
Like I said, there's enough for everybody.
I'mmma take my little bit, have me a
cigar and keep it movin'.
- Is it my shot? I think it's your shot.
- It's your shot.
- Oh, it's my shot? OK.
- I gotta, I gotta make one, bro.
- If it's not your shot, I'll give it to you
cuz you need some help.
- Lemme get this one right here.
- You got a lotta kids in the street.
- You feelin' charitable.
How was it like for you
to win a Super Bowl? We had, we had Jacoby
Jones on Season 1, also a New Orleans native.
- Yeah.
- That, that—I loved
talkin' to him.
- That's my boy.
- Season 1, we talked to him about
being able to win in New Orleans.
- Yeah.
- Winnin' the Super Bowl in New Orleans.
I wanna ask you after I take this shot
real quick, you know what I'm sayin'?
- Yeah, I know. I'm tryna get this out
your way, man.
I'm tryna help you out.
- What was it like for you as a New Orleans native—
- Yeah, I'm from New Orleans. I'm from that city.
- To win the Super Bowl?
- So, for, for us to go back home, it was everything
to me, man.
So the week we're going to New Orleans for
the Super Bowl, I had to give a speech to
the guys about not eatin' a lotta food.
Cuz I'm like, "Dude, come Wednesday, Thursday,
don't be eatin' all this food, man.
You're gonna be heavy and sluggish."
- I wanna give you a spoiler alert.
Jacoby Jones
did not listen. His momma was cookin' gumbo
and everything.
- My mom cooked too for the guys.
Nah, he listened. Everybody listened. Jacoby shoulda got MVP.
Had two touchdowns.
Kickoff return.
Come on, man.
- That's real.
- You know,
so, I'm like, "Guys, be mindful, man,
eatin' the food."
You know what I'm sayin'?
I brought crawfish and everything to the
hotels for the boys, you know, but we still
on a business trip, so treat it as such,
you know?
And plus, man, I'm in my backyard.
I'm not losin' in my backyard.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I ate oysters every day, so...everybody
know what oysters will do for you.
- [Laughing]
- Come pregame,
I was jacked up!
You know what I'm sayin'?
I actually hurt myself in the first quarter.
I hurt both of my MCLs.
I sprained both of them.
- Sprained 'em both,
yeah.
- Yeah, man.
So, but, but to, to do it at home, man, it
was a true ble—I can't really even
describe winning a championship at home.
You know what I'm sayin'?
We was the last team to play in the
Superdome before Katrina hit, right?
We were the first team to play in the
Super Bowl in New Orleans after Katrina.
So for me, it's, it's a lot, man. Special, man.
It's so much.
You know, I look at Baltimore and New
Orleans as twin cities because of the
stuff that they experienced in the inner cities.
- Economically, the way it's structured, yeah.
- Yeah, man. you watch "Treme,"
you watch "The Wire"—
- Same, same—yeah.
- You get a real good glimpse of how the cities are,
you know?
So it was special to me, man.
And now Baltimore, New Orleans people,
when they get together, man, it's a blast.
It's a party.
- So that—was it—
- Is it my shot?
- Yeah, it's your
shot right now.
I made two real quick.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I didn't wanna embarrass myself, so—that was a nice shot.
Correct me if I'm wrong:
That was your last game as a Raven.
- That was my last game as a Raven,
unfortunately, yes.
- Did you know it was gonna end there?
- I had a clue.
I had a clue it was gonna end there
because when Ray Lewis became a free
agent, I was at the house with him, and
they didn't offer him too much, so it's
a business, man.
I learned a lot from Steve Bisciotti,
Ozzie Newsome, those guys, you know, and
they taught me so much.
Excuse me for turnin' my back to you
guys, but they taught me so much about the
business, so I wasn't surprised when I
called, cuz I didn't have an agent.
I was my own agent.
I called and I'm like, "What's goin' on?
What we doin'?"
And they were like, "We don't have nothin' for you."
I'm like, "Not even a dollar?"
They didn't offer me a dollar. Not a dime.
So I was like, "All right, my time is up."
You know, my time is up. So I was all right with it.
- I think I said in the Super Bowl, it was, it was
a MCL
sprain? Was it a tear?
- I had a second-degree
MCL sprain on my left leg and the first-
degree on my right.
So as much as I wanted to pick off three
and four picks from Kaepernick, cuz I knew
I had 'em, I couldn't move.
- Mhm.
You know what I'm sayin'?
And to be honest with you, that was—we
played the Saints in the Superdome so many times.
That was the only interception I ever had
in the Superdome.
- Wow.
- Yeah, man.
We partied one time down there, like, 2006. We
was kickin' they butt, and the boys on the
sideline dancin', doin' everything.
Everybody from Louisiana—we had, like, five
guys on the team from Louisiana.
Everybody except for me caught an interception that
game. But in the Super Bowl, when it
counts, the hawk showed up.
- You stepped up. You stepped up.
- Yes, sir.
- So the Ravens have seen you comin' off the
injury in the Superdo—in the Super Bowl.
You're getting older. Your time's up there.
You end up spending time with the Houston Texans.
You reunited with Andre Johnson.
- If I'd have stayed in Baltimore,
I'd still be playin' today.
- You think so?
- I know so.
- Why?
- Because, man, I just had, I had everything
goin' the right way.
I had my doctor, training, everything.
When I went to Houston, it took me back to
the South, and it was so discouraging.
If y'all remember, um, rest in peace to
him, Bob McNair,
but outta respect.
Um, if y'all remember when we were goin'
through certain things in the NFL, you
remember he said, "You can't let the
prisoners run the prison."
He was the guy that say that.
I saw that before.
I saw that when I was in, when I was there.
You know—
- The way he ran things, or—
- How, how—the Houston way, so to say, that they
called it. You know, and it's not the
city, it's the organization, you know, at
the time.
And they had that old-school mentality,
man. You had coaches talkin' reckless to guys.
You know?
And I'm like, as a grown man, how do you
let that happen?
And plus, as a coach, you're not gonna
get everything out of that man that you
want because you talkin' to him reckless.
I was surrounded by a bunch of guys just
comin' to work.
It was a job.
It wasn't football anymore.
And for me, that was, like, draining.
That was very draining, man.
And, "You actually brought me in, recruited
me and asked me to tell you the things
that I'm tellin' you.
And when I started sayin' that stuff,
they shrugged me off, you know? It was like,
"Eh, that's, that's not how we do it."
So I was lied to.
I'm too old to be lied to, and I'm too old
to play these games with people who, you
know, say you gotta play the game to get higher.
I'm not playin' the game.
I ain't got time for that.
I'll go do something else.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I'll go work back at Blockbuster.
I worked at Blockbuster when I was here in
college, so, kids, you could have a job.
- So you went from there. Then you went to the Jets.
And then how'd you know it was time to
hang it up at that point?
Cuz you're sharin' right now that you
feel like you could still be playing.
- Only reason, only reason I retired
was to bring some joy to Baltimore.
Freddie Gray had just got killed, man.
And I was sittin' in my house in Georgia.
It was like, "You know what?
I'm done."
You know, I let these young folk have it.
Let one of these young kids make the
roster and let him make some money.
Man, I'm good.
I took care of my finances, still take
care of my finances.
So I wasn't, I wasn't one of those old
guys, like, need to stay playin', you know?
So I was like, "Bring some joy back home."
And I started buildin' my foundation up in
Baltimore even more.
- Why'd you feel it was on you to bring
the city joy through your retirement
during a really rough time for that city?
- Cuz, I mean, I was in that light, you
know? It's kinda like Kobe, man. You're
in that light.
What can you do,
you know? How, how can—cuz all we here to
do is leave this place a better place than
we got it when we came.
- Preach.
- You know?
So as for me and my advisor Glenn, my
director of my foundation, started talkin'
about doin' more stuff in the community.
Man, we went—I went from my first year
startin' my foundation, feedin' 30 people
with my financial advisor, Brad Davis,
feedin' 30 people.
We used to go to the store ourselves, pick
up the bags, pick up
the turkeys, the fixings and everything.
Excuse me, and bag it ourselves.
Bring it to Booker T. Washington.
We went from 30 to now 20 years later,
feedin' like, 5,000.
- Dope.
- You know, so that's what it's about.
- That's incredible, man.
That's incredible.
- You know, that, that's what it's about.
But I felt like, you know, I was
gettin' calls from the White House. Like,
call—like, "Make an Instagram post to the
kids and tell 'em to go home during the
Baltimore riots."
I said, "That's got to be the stupidest
thing I ever heard."
Why?
Because ain't no—nobody who's rioting
is lookin' at their damn phone.
They damn sure not out there
takin' pictures like, "We out here
gettin' stuff."
I'm not about to do that.
- And who couldn't you relate to more,
the White House or these kids protestin'?
- The kids!
Cuz I know why it got to that point.
I work with Booker T. Washington in Baltimore.
They don't give these kids a chance.
These kids come down the street,
and there's more abandoned buildings, just
like you've seen on "The Wire." They
walkin' past those abandoned buildings.
They might have one that's bein' housed.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, these kids go to school with no hope in
Baltimore, man.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, it was easy for me to deny that because
they're the root of it.
The government won't allow you to do
nothin' in the schools.
The government won't allow you to take
care of our kids.
The kids are our future.
How,
how as a human being, as a grown person,
that you deny a kid opportunity? A kid
is innocent.
You got kids raisin' kids in Baltimore,
man, because they mamas are strung out on
stuff.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
That's around the world.
But what I know, in Baltimore, we need help.
We need help, and and don't get me wrong,
Baltimore is not a bad city.
We got a bad rep, but when you go visit
Baltimore—
- I have a good time, man.
- You gonna have a great time.
- I have a good time.
- You have a great time, man.
Go visit, go visit Bygone and—well, you can't
get in the Elk Room unless you know me,
you're with me.
- I'm cool witchu.
- Yeah, you cool, man.
- I'm ready.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
But they got a lotta nice spots, and be
more—you know what I'm sayin'?
Well, you can go and enjoy yourself
and have a good time, and a lotta history there.
you know?
- I admired—
I mean, we can go to your Hall of Fame
speech now as you're wearin' the Hall of Fame
ring around your neck. I admired how you
used the platform to speak about Black
Lives Matter and police brutality.
You spoke earlier about how you felt the,
the, the platform that you had and the
prominence that you have, the weight on
your shoulders to do these things and
speak out on these issues.
- Yeah.
- But why in that particular space, when
everyone's celebrating you, that you
decided to give light on Black Lives Matter
and police brutality?
- Cuz that moment wasn't about me.
I didn't get there by myself, so why am I
gonna get up there and talk about what
you already saw on the highlight reel?
You know what I'm sayin'?
You already know what Ed did.
Now you wanna know what,
what was Ed off the football field?
What, what—who
were the people in his life, you know,
to help him get, get to that point?
What are the things that affect you as a
human being?
You know what I'm sayin'?
And that's the time to do it.
You know?
Nothin' to him, but that's why I thought
T.O. should've went, because now you have the
platform to say all the things you wanna say.
You know?
So, for me, it was just, it was just tryin'
to bring light to the world, man.
Like, all police are not bad, dude.
My brother's a police officer.
I mean, he played with me and, um, he's
actually Miami Beach police, you know, so.
It's just so much, man, that, that was on my mind.
There's a lotta stuff I actually left out
because they was, like, hittin' the time.
You know, they only give you, like, 10
minutes or 15 minutes to speak.
- Before, they used to let everybody speak
for as long as they wanted to, and
then they started—
- Exactly.
You know, but it is, I mean, it gets long.
You know what I'm sayin'?
You got a lotta old guys
there, sittin' there.
I'm gonnna be there this year and be
there every year, smokin' a cigar. You
know, listenin' to my guys.
But that's the time, man, at which you
can bring light to the world, man.
You can, you can help somebody out.
You know, you can, you can talk about
issues that affected you and people would
never know. Like, thinkin' you're perfect.
People, people put us on a high pedestal because
we played a sport.
When in all actual reality, we're
human just like everybody else.
- That's real.
- We're no different.
We just worked our ass off to play, to be
really good.
Just watch. You work your ass off, you can
do the same thing.
It's no different.
It really is just, you know, the heart
gotta be there.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, at the end of that day, we human beings, man.
And that's what I tell a lotta pictures
I got on my 'Gram. I'll be like, "No pics."
You know, I got this "no pic" thing goin'
around cuz it is outta hand, man!
There's a camera everywhere, and it's not
just these cameras. It's the cameras you
got in your phone, in your pocket.
You know, everybody got a camera. From a,
from a seven-, eight-year-old to a 88-year-old,
you know? And everybody feel like
they entitled to your time, your picture.
Come on, man. I'm just as human as you.
Walkin' down the street.
"Hey, Ed, what's up man?"
"Cool."
"How you doin'?"
It's like you're seein' your boy down in—
walkin' up the street, walkin' on the side of the street.
"What's up, bro?"
You holla at him, keep it movin'.
That's how it used to be back in the old
days before all these phones came along.
- Things have changed.
Technology done changed everything, man.
- But that's my—that's, that's, that's part
of my gripe in this world is that the
forefathers didn't foresee that when they
wrote the Constitution and all that stuff.
You see what I'm sayin'?
So we're still livin' under some of those laws, man.
We're still livin' under some of those ways.
And they didn't foresee the internet.
They didn't foresee that stuff.
That stuff affects our livelihood different.
- Ed, I can talk to you for, like, another
five or six hours.
- I got time.
- We gotta wrap it up here.
But, Ed, thank you so much for takin' the
time out during the Super Bowl week,
spendin' time here on "Untold Stories." It's
the perfect way for us to wrap up Season 1.
I wish you nothin' but the best this week as
we also celebrate you on Sunday at the
Super Bowl during NFL 100 being a member of that.
Congratulations on that as well.
- Word.
- So, thank you for the time, and I also
wanted to end this game before you busted my ass.
- Yeah, where's my shot on the eight ball?
I appreciate y'all havin' me here, man.
- You wanna go ahead and finish this off real quick?
- Takin' the time out y'all day to come
watch us shoot pool and me smoke a
cigar and bust you down in pool.
I'mma put it right here.
- Go ahead, you got it right here.
- It's a scratch shot.
I'mma try not to scratch.
- Let's, let's play this out real quick.
Let's see.
- You go ahead, do your thing!
- Let's see if we can play this out.
- You got a lotta kids in the street.
Only thing I'm tryna do is get from under these
cookin' lights.
I feel like a, I feel like a chicken roastin' right now.
Turn 'em!
- What would be your dream coaching job?
- My dream coaching job, probably head coach.
It'd definitely be head coaching.
Um, and I can't limit myself.
I won't limit myself.
I'd coach anywhere, man. You know, almost anywhere.
Cuz it depends on who your boss, who you
work for.
That's in any profession, man.
If your boss a jerk, you're gonna be
getting it every day.
You know, if your boss in the NFL don't
like his wife and don't wanna go home,
you gonna be there a long time.
You know, so I'mma put it right there.
- You sure you got it, cuz—
I'mma bring my slice out real quick.
- They said they gotta wrap it up right here.
I'm hopin' you kinda scratched, lowkey.
- It ain't gonna scratch.
You wanna win like that?
- I'll take a
win however I can get it.
Feel me?
- That is true.
A win's a win.
- Let's wrap this up real quick.
- So we got any San Fran fans in here?
- There you go.
- There's your shot right there.
- K.C. fans?
- There's a San Fran fan right there.
- Who's, who's winnin' the game?
- [Fan:] 49ers!
- Hey, man, you by yourself.
You better be careful, man.
That's about right.
- And you made it, man.
Ed, man.
My man.
Thank you so much, man.
- I enjoyed it, bro.
- No doubt.
- Appreciate you guys who tuned in.
Thanks for supporting us all season long.
I'm Master.
I'm out.
See you guys in Season 2.
Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R
to check out more dope videos like this one.